thank you what are you doing well not
anymore you're not we're playing the
deepest sleep how's it going Brad my
beard back this game has the highest
rating I have ever seen on gamejolt
though this game better blow me away
well I suppose we start with part two
then well [ __ ] me then I guess we'll
just start a new game I mean I haven't
played the first two points but as a
great woman once said if you haven't
done the first two parts then you can
just play a bit anyway I said that
actually I'm not a woman I wake up and
admit I I think I wake up in the middle
of the night I couldn't move or say
anything oh yeah sleep apparel eye
analysis and there was someone in my
room he definitely has it oh god oh god
this actually happened to me one time
when I was a kid
this little skeleton just it's it's
someone there oh my god I can't move he
seems to be looking at me just don't
come oh god damn what the [ __ ] was that
why would you do that [ __ ] what is wrong
with you oh great I'm in a nightmare
hello I'll have this bottle of oh that
opened the door hallelujah
oh we got some glowy eyes well I'll be
going back then
well [ __ ] me I guess we have to hallo oh
okay
oh it's not ice it's dead rubies no it's
not rubies alright so restore all a
double ax Dolph can't get Lana COFF COFF
alone a pink upon all the dude off we're
going in this way Bruce we have a little
puddle hello Burt
I'm sure this note gets to you somehow
so your father's stupid traveler even
though you knew what's gonna happen you
are at the bottom death now there is
nothing beneath you this guy seems mean
it's important that you avoid the bottom
Peters they feed with their ass or that
sounds like a truly terrifying monster
they sense motion so don't make any
sudden moves near them also don't go
near the dark Church the darkness there
will suffocate you well that's good to
know find a ladder that should take you
back there's ever since early yourself
oh wow
hiya I am a gentleman no handle huh well
how do we we have this sealed vase let's
try it it didn't work well what are you
gonna do well let's go in here then I
suppose hello we got a broom uh-huh
we have some fog cans smells like paint
moldy and stinky hello hello the
bottom-feeders
yes I want to know more about how they
do that they live at the bottom layer of
the realm of dreams feeding upon
everything that ends up there even poop
that's why they're called the bottom
Peters not because of the dream thing
even the shadow people fear them they
are blind but can sense vibrations and
boom it's so staying perfectly still you
should be you should be what I should be
what I got a screwdriver let's and a
hammer that's and can we go here oh hi
there I'm not gonna go near you no
keyhole or handle but there is that
thing or if you use the hammer on it no
I can't do a gemma stuck in this
dentures man well what if we combine
this screwdriver would the statue there
we go I got the gem in your face gem gem
it's truly outrageous truly truly truly
outrageous oh here you go [ __ ] somebody
one more huh
oh so [ __ ] smart all minecraft in my
ass man oh my god you I am impressed of
myself I should take a selfie there we
go
I did something hello Oh God shadow
people this is actually [ __ ] scary
man we got another gem a small hole
let's put the gem in there why don't we
shout we do that
Oh minecraft are more of them there's so
many I feel a little lost to be honest
it's a lot of bees in here I don't like
bees and not beeps either for that
matter okay we just have to find all the
gems and put them in the hole there we
go oh we found the boomerang yes of
course yes of course finally I looked
everywhere for this boomerang we are
free I have a boomerang I'll be right
back sir I'll be right back with my
boomerang alright then boomerang go
boomerang go and let's spin that [ __ ]
yeah yeah this store should be open
alright thanks mate see you later oh god
it's so wet and nice and done in it not
nice it's wet some Nick what why do I go
this way oh god there's giant slugs in
here I'm not a big fan man I guess we go
here oh hi cloud man are you doing mate
yeah have a have a chair why not
red rope what if we smash his face
no let's read this super gate lock
system okay we have the thing that opens
there that opens that but it closes the
bars and it's somehow connected to this
clown man god damn you clown man so what
if we give him the chair what if we poke
his eyes out what if we give him a nose
job well you are just being picky and
[ __ ] right now
mr. clown so what if we found something
to block the door I put oh minecraft you
see that Jerry I am solving these
puzzles like I cheated but I didn't I
swear I would never cheat you maybe I've
done it a couple times on other games
but never in this game every go
fantastic Thanks
is it dark enough I might I'll see you
later let's go through here with a giant
sluggish overlay do lead off king kelana
COFF COFF alone and pink upon it all
they do lead off okay here it is oh
hello giant slug oh my god giant slug
and I wasn't supposed to move I forgot
let's go this way I suppose okay uh-huh
very interesting well I guess we have to
go this way don't move
sorry about that oh sorry about that oh
sorry sorry
oh it's totally as a key in his ass a
mouth well really that could be anything
I've honestly I feel more comfortable
thinking that tininess no way come on
don't chicken out come on man oh God
okay okay there's a switch gentle gentle
Bruce gentle gentle
okay I've got it's timed Oh God uh no oh
come on
yes Oh with Billy porch at Joe's high
five oh that's not a high five mayor get
used to it nothing nothing and I think
well I'm glad we could still do that I'm
not going back there why not it does it
wasn't that bad music box that's creepy
weird as bathrooms no water but if I
need to poop I know this is weird
interesting pasa I don't know it could
be like an AI could be like an ballerina
and another guy just dancing a girl with
a skirt and a guy dancing that's how
that's what my brain made out of that
but there has to be a solution maybe it
has something to do with the music box
what about the screwdriver bad idea what
what's wrong with my ideas they're
amazing
what there was a car in the sank oh my
god amazing I'm so fancy
shut up it's Thursday all right there's
nothing but darkening death here we
gotta something that's blocking that
empty square
okay let's take over here what am I
having here okay I'm a little weirded
out we have a bunny nice bunny and
that's it alright we have some bunny
what about here we have a calf I wind up
cot we can use I said a kitty cat uh-huh
a lot of puzzles there at once I'm all
confused by it
let's go and wind up that [ __ ] oh hello
oh nice
wow that turned into that Oh wonderful
oh that's so nice and one two three go
don't if there you go
very painful well we have a vivid
imagination I give you that
oh god this place really [ __ ] up that
name no come on I can't even go here get
out God okay yeah hey add some chocolate
stone tablet oh jesus [ __ ] ass okay
then well I don't know why did he have a
stone tablet
what's that before it's Steve but Steve
times what is this okay it's another
claw it's the same trial Allah but I
don't understand it what about the stone
tablet you go but some tablets doesn't
feel anything I don't understand why you
say that to me oh oh oh oh oh damn we
need four of them though that's a
problem though isn't it there's totally
one in here
it's a lid maybe we can use a
screwdriver to get it open
Oh minecraft and then let's use it again
I guess Oh minecraft stuck for good
[ __ ] oh now we stop the machinery
Amazon we can go in here no don't kill
me please
this does not seem safe who would invent
stuff like this who thought that was a
good idea
it's like pimp my house oh you know what
I want I want walls that will eat you
yeah that's cool a cinnamon toast oh my
god I love cinnamon chest I wonder have
it and up there I wonder that too rotten
meat dried herb suspicious looking
drying her should be there yeah there we
go we got it cool
there must be something liquid inside
maybe maybe it's the gas oh boy that
sure was fun and we got another stone
tablet amazing oh I need to put them in
the order of the puzzle got it
alright well I'll figure that out later
we just need to worry about getting all
the tablets right now
a mushroom big fat generally just like
my bike oh that is a nasty greasy oil oh
hello hello and a stone tablet Wow
amazing amazing amazing shut up
okay sorry what about here no we check
this out so we're missing one and we
have some point so maybe oh yeah we can
use the oil here and then we open and
then we just go down and oh god oh god
oh god oh god oh god oh god oh my got to
beerus oh my god a gig it's [ __ ]
terrifying let's just get it oh god do
you have that butthole man that [ __ ]
bottle of death and suffering shoosh go
away all right
Genta just gonna go up again let's go
down get this [ __ ] he's still there oh I
can go right here yeah bah what God I
got a hiccup at the same time sorry
barrels
pile of plates interesting
can I go forward please what if I break
them with a hammer
oh I attracted the giant potala and your
face barrels yes what you gonna do help
out my new shoes what you gonna do about
today it we're progressing pretty good
I'm pretty proud of you breasts
Oh minecraft a ladder I can't reach it
we found the ladder oh oh oh oh oh oh
bottle bottle bottle hurry okay go oh my
god the giant bottle almost got us
Oh God Oh Oh what is that it's it's is
that of me Luigi I'm one of the but
people now I remember
they've got me oh yeah I remember that
from the old one that I didn't play all
this time I've been one of them
dad inception noise oh my god and it
keeps going I'm a monster
I'm one of them well it's not all bad
does that mean I have to kill people now
that's all listen there he was a
traveler just like me before the moment
he saw me he stated raining I just find
it a heck may ticket out of here my
chance to finally wake up
get him I just had to catch him to
possess a sleeping buddy a buddy that I
could wake up in get him but did I
really want you have I really become a
monster so easily a monster and beard so
much I liked him you think so I get a
choice here it was so easy almost too
easy
I took his body away leaving him in in
this chaotic world I wake up now and the
chaos of this place will follow me up to
the surface
[ __ ] you that was too deep asleep a game
made by script welder
I was pretty awesome I didn't expect it
to be this good I'm gonna have to play
the first two ones now yeah I was a cool
game I'll leave a link to this in the
description if you want to check it out
and I hope you have a great day stay
awesome bros and thank you for liking my
butt